[Music]
last thanksgiving i don't know if you
remember this but we showed a holiday
commercial on our show for something
called the gravy boat lighthouse yeah it
was a very weird commercial if you
didn't see it it was for an unusual
product it was a it was a pro it was for
a lighthouse that insane people can use
insane people who think their gravy boat
is a real boat right okay it's a very
niche product exactly and the light the
lighthouse would guide in the gravy boat
safely right to the turkey and stuffing
and um well anyway uh apparently it's
sold a lot of them been successful yeah
four were sold so
now the same company apparently i'm told
has a new product out for the holidays
that i think maybe complements last
year's product let's uh let's take a
look at the commercial
and then he found his shoe
gravy please sure
are you an insane person who thinks that
your gravy boat is a real boat in danger
of being hijacked by somalian gravy
pirates pirates
no no no
protect the gravy from the
pirates the anti-piracy gravy boat gun
then
gravy
turret
[Music]
from the makers of the gravy boat
lighthouse only 24.99 99 9.
[Applause]